i love the indulgence in this dish
if i was doing this for the kids i'd
scrap the vodka and just do like a
virgin mary
but
it's a bit of a grown-ups dish
now pan nice and hot splash of olive oil
onions in
seasoning touch of salt and pepper
garlic
be nice and generous with your garlic
it's not just your average tomato sauce
it's a royal stunning tomato sauce and
you're in for a big treat
your onions and garlic the tabasco
that will give that really nice lift
little pinch of celery salt
spice that up with worcester sauce
it instantly colors the tomatoes goes
brilliantly well with a celery salt
tabasco and that nice caramelized garlic
a little light sprinkling of sugar all
the worcester sauce
has reduced down we've got this nice
sweet spicy sticky garlicky onion base
glaze with a couple of spoons of vodka
in
lovely
chopped tomatoes in
little touch of water
look at the color
on that sauce
check the seasoning
that's delicious
bring that up to the boil and cook it
out six to eight minutes reduce it down
slowly turn down the gas and let that
simmer
with my sauce simmering i can move on to
a delicious breadcrumb topping to dress
my linguini
i'll fry off my breadcrumbs get them
nice and crispy but don't put too much
oil in there otherwise the bread will
just absorb it they become greasy
beautifully season them
and they go really nice and golden brown
30 seconds before they come out flat
leaf parsley roll that through
your breadcrumbs
and that is gonna finish the linguine on
top
you can hear how crispy they are
before i cook the linguini i'm gonna
make the chili butter that will flavor
my lobster
get your chili and slice it i want to
take advantage of all those seeds
chili in
a touch of salt
a nice clove of garlic
here's some parsley
[Music]
start breaking that down but i'm looking
for a lovely garlic chili paste exactly
like that
now don't overdo it with the butter
herb butters are a great way to flavor
fish and meat they can be used as a
stuffing in dishes like chicken kiev or
added towards the end of a dish as a
delicious glaze
lobsters
they're already cooked so
firmly place the lobster flat on your
board there's a little crisscross here
line there and line going across
put the point of the knife in and just
push through
the head
turn the lobster around
cut through the lobster
snap the legs off
snap the claws off just get the back of
your knife
crack them
spread that beautiful butter on
go into the heads as well
and then the claws
take off bits of the shell
and get little bits of butter in there
this can be done way in advance for me
the longer that chili butter sits on top
of that lobster the better the flavor
especially when they hit the grill
while my lobster firms up in the fridge
i can finish cooking my linguini
water
brought up to the boil
seasoned nicely and a little touch of
olive oil
now linguine in first that's going to
take the longest eight to ten minutes
in
as linguine starts softening at the
bottom just gently turn that around
always wait the linguine is nice and
soft that way you don't break those nice
strands
give that a good mix get your lid back
on
[Music]
and bring that to the ball rapidly
after eight to ten minutes my linguini
should be perfect
you want it al dente slightly firm
not too chewy
absolutely spot on
drain that
into a colander
shake a little bit of water from the
pasta into my sauce
and she goes
start twisting
the linguini
around i want that bloody mary spicing
up the linguine
always hold up the center of the pan
first and place it onto the plate
let go of that nice big lump
by doing this you'll get a mountainous
pile of spaghetti with more body
then generously cover that your crispy
breadcrumbs absolutely beautiful
last but not least i need to cook my
chilled herb buttered lobsters on a
smoking hot griddle
that butter's gone really nice and firm
so the idea is
snapping that down
and grilling
the smell of that chili and garlic
butter is extraordinary because the
lobster's cooked all you're doing is
grilling that delicious spicy chili
butter
you just want that mark of the char
quickly on the lobster
turn that over
smell is incredible
[Music]
now get that on
[Music]
you can understand why it is proper
special occasion food because
that is mind blowing
griddled lobster with chili and garlic
butter serves with a boozy bloody merry
linguine a sensational special occasion
lunch
get that pan nice and hot recognize that
fillet of beef this is a rolls-royce cup
of beef so we've got to treat it with
some respect okay yeah mop up all that
seasoning yeah
into the pan
and get that really nice and hot hello
[Music]
cooking with these aromatic herbs and
garlic will add flavor to the beef
because it's a fillet of beef
there's hardly any fat on there so you
sear it quickly
ends as well gets seared i'm gonna now
put some butter in there
continue frying all those herbs
now baste that with the butter
see
dad are we just having this or are we
gonna have something with it now we're
gonna serve some beautiful baked
potatoes with truffle and a salsa verde
into the oven eight to ten minutes
that's all
next my super special bake new potatoes
wash and drain small new potatoes and
tip into a baking tray
drizzle with olive oil then season with
a touch of salt and freshly ground black
pepper
place into an oven preheated at 180
degrees celsius and bake for 35 minutes
until crisp on the outside and soft all
the way through
transfer to your serving dish and grate
over fresh parmesan cheese
last but not least shave gorgeous earthy
black truffle slivers onto the cheesy
potatoes
bake new potatoes with a lavish twist
indulgent but couldn't be simpler to
make
right salsa birthday
anchovies you'll touch your vancouver
oil in there okay we have anchovies
after that we've got some capers
garlic
in with the anchovies and the capers
okay a touch
of salt one only a touch because you
call the salt in the actually that's
right well then diesel mustard
sherry vinegar give that a nice mix
now this is where it starts to go to a
completely different level some fresh
mint and some fresh parsley i want half
of it in there
pureed
a touch of olive oil in there in
the rest of the mint
a touch of salt
pepper
you excited
yep
you know taste
those i'd love some of these
what's it taste like
fat
might need to try a tiny bit more
just to check
stop
you can't kiss any boys now
before the kids polish off all the
sounds of
i need a distraction and i think my b
phillip will do the job nicely
look at this baby hot holes
up
look at that
seared and look how juicy
and tender that is
take that out and let that sit
on there
a little spoon just while it sits and
rests obviously early as the beef cools
down that south of the other marinades
that
goes to the table very carefully please
tails this is my ultimate special
occasion dinner
the tenderest rare beef fillet with
punchy salsa velde
served with extravagant truffled new
potatoes
you